what if the 15 year-olds watch this and
they're like yeah obviously they're not
going to do as well as us they're all my
name is Clark and I'm kind of active but
I hate gyms in comparison to this dude
right here I'm pretty athletic in high
school I did wrestling wrestling was so
intense so I quit wrestling and joined
musical theater I'm pretty athletic I
used to break dance I used to be active
when I was younger I would played every
sport you can think of I think I am much
more athletic in my mind than I am in
body I try to go to the gym like four
days a week yeah I think that's ability
test right I sucked at this thing this
is the worst part of gym for me today we
take indeed New York State I just wonder
better than a 15 year old girl it says
an 11-year old boy can do 47 curl ups
six
not 1011
oh my god my food is about how you dip
push and keep going that's how winning
is done
30 40 so for an 11 year old male the
goal is 26 push-ups 12 beat you tiny
third - 14 - wow you weren't kidding
31 man that was close you did good you
almost beat that at 15 yo I'm upset
disappointed in myself either you're
gonna do worse than a kid or gonna do
better than a kid yeah when you get a
brag about walk out here it's like his
whole upper body is like my whole life
you gotta make your leg straight sir no
chance and so for females they have to
go this 24th that's exactly 24th
yeah well I gotta go 31 Oh
bought that I probably would be able to
perform at an 11-year olds
I'm standard totally let's say there's
my crotch and Here I am trying to do
push-ups he's gonna be disappointed at
the girl who couldn't do more than three
but if you're good at something it makes
you happy do it if that's sports do it
if it's not sports that's okay it may
not seem like it's okay right now but I
promise you you'll be shocked at how
okay it is spread body positivity all
right I was voted the most athletic girl
in high school and look at me now look
at me now you know so this could be you
so don't don't talk too fast about that
person that can only do five push-ups
flexibility test anymore look at this
this guy is genius can you Canyon Canyon
Canyon